[Musique]
tous les regards se tournent vers lui
que sait-on de se barrer en radial le
variant indien le variant indien est à
nos portes
et pour cause le variant indien fait des
ravages à l'intérieur du pays avec plus
de 300000 contamination quotidienne hier
près de 350 mille personnes ont été
contaminées en variant double mutants
qui suscite l'inquiétude car il serait
plus contagieux il pourrait rendre les
vaccins moins efficace contagieux et cas
de ce variant déjà été détectés en
europe vendredi matin 20 étudiants ont
été testés positifs à ce nouveau variant
se rendent en belgique n'est passant par
l'aéroport de roissy un super
contaminateur parmi les passagers
pourraient être à l'origine de ce foyer
épidémique
alors que les services de réanimation
enfants sont encore pleins et que le
gouvernement s'apprête à lancer son plan
de déconfinement l'arrivée de ce nouveau
variant pourrait venir tout changer
alors variant indien la situation en
france peut-elle devenir hors de
contrôle
alors le vario indien déjà eu il ya des
symptômes dont on va parler
martin blanchet merci d'être là déjà
merci à vous et merci avec june aravane
merci journaliste indienne d'être avec
nous également
ce soir c'est vrai qu'on saigne du nez
et on peut saigner de la bouche
c'est ça le les intérieurs et des
tableaux qui serait un petit peu
différent mais moi je pense qu'il faut
différencier ce qui se passe en inde et
le variant indien il se passera rebond
épidémique incroyable en inde
effectivement et après il ya un variant
qui a émergé et la coke et b la cause
qu'elle ait fait c'est assez difficile
d'en savoir plus et arthur se marier en
anglais l'indien on sait quasiment rien
il ya très très peu de données qui ont
été publiés donc on voit les images de
l'inde
invalidation cataclysmique et à ce
variant sur lequel pour l'instant on ne
sait pas grand chose et voilà on sait
pas exactement ce qu'il en est sa
contagiosité sa létalité là les formes
cliniques qu'ils occasionnent donc pour
l'instant on parle beaucoup de la
situation indienne on rapprochera du
variant comme on l'a déjà fait pour
d'autres pays
c'est très très difficile de savoir at
il alors moi je suis beaucoup plus
pessimiste je suis pas médecin mais
quand même les images d'un des puits ce
variant indien en quelques jours
le voilà au royaume uni en guadeloupe
celui-ci en suisse et on a l'impression
encore une fois que nos aéroports sont
des pochoiristes les gens étaient
contaminés est-ce que c'est pas déjà
trop tard pourquoi l'océan indien soit
stoppé les lames agiles à chaque fois de
façon qui en variant qui émerge quelque
part et qu'un variant qui gagne sur les
autres variant il est partout dans le
monde et s'est pas laissée pas une
exception du mariage indien c'est tout
le temps comme ça parce qu'en fait le
variant une fois qu'on l'a identifié il
a déjà diffusé partout et ça c'est
l'histoire de cette épidémie
après ce qu'il en est vraiment de se
voir et l'indien on n'en sait rien tous
les spécialistes avec qui tu demanderas
que durant il n'y a pas de publication
pour l'instant donc on sait on ne sait
pas exactement combien de cas en inde
parce qu'ils n'ont pas du tout la même
stratégie de dépistage que nous mais
est-ce que ce que c'est pareil on y
circule déjà en france à votre avis ou
pas mais c'est très probablement et
circule dans l'arrivée pays qui sont
autour de la france dont il ya quand
même peu de chances qu'ils circulent pas
du tout en france
oui quels sont les risques parce que à
chaque fois on dit oui c'est ça
le maillot anglais on les dit attendez
on va il faut voir quinze jours après il
était partout apparemment le brésilien
il habille les du mal à prendre le pas
sur l'anglais qui possède une bêtise
donc ton idée de ce qu'est un vrai sur
le variant indien et le vaccin c'est la
question serait de savoir est ce que le
vario indien peut gagner contre le vhc à
regret a priori ce que disent les gens
qui ont étudié un petit peu les
mutations disent probablement pas le
variant britannique resterait
supplantant le variant indien qui est
très peu présent assez bien pour
l'instant à ce qu'il paraît que l'on dit
que le variant brésilien le vaccin de
n'a aucun effet sur lui n'en sais rien
on sait que dans le tube effectivement
est la moins d'effet mais on n'a pas
encore essayé le vaccin sur le varia
brésilien dans des conditions on avait
dit ça sur le variant sud africain
visiblement le vaccin de pfizer est très
efficace sur variant sud-africain donc
on attend de voir on n'a pas encore les
données
alors vas y joue une aravane merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes journaliste
indienne la situation est catastrophique
on en a oui totalement totalement c'est
qu'est ce qui s'est passé que c'est ça a
été très vite une situation qui s'est
envenimée très très vite avec sow
variant oui parce que le gouvernement a
fait plusieurs erreurs
c'est habile au début ils ont fait un
local mais qui était le pic du monde sur
le personnel exactement ça ne pouvait
bouger ils viennent dans 40 millions de
travailleurs journaliers qui a été
obligé des petites et des grandes villes
justement durlin pied l'inde au départ
était cité en exemple aux essais de
masséna puis là c'est une catastrophe et
il ya eu une espèce de triomphalisme
tout ça en disant qu on a vaincu en avec
qui on va sortir de ça on a commencé à
ouvrir les cinémas les piscines les
restaurants les gens commençaient à la
vue de ces images on a déjà tout sommet
ont séduit rien n'était et c'est là où
le gouvernement s'est pas préparé
correctement pour d'anticiper cette
deuxième troisième vague ça fait
extrêmement peur ce qui se passe en
mains moi j'ai vu des images de gens qui
saignait du nez qui qui crache et du son
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression d'être
dans un mauvais film d'horreur investi
c'est terrifiant deuxièmement il n'y a
pas assez d'oxygène puis
le fait que ont ainsi naît de l'école
comme ça il vient pas des crématoriums
électrique ne soit complètement débordé
donc ça nous ramène à des images dans
cette fois et ça donne l'image d'un pays
qui est vraiment rentré dans le siècle
dernier loue même un plus tôt martin
blachier c'est vrai que l'inde au départ
tout le monde disait franchement ils ont
très bien géré la crise sanitaire donc
et comme l a dit cette journaliste c'est
vrai que très vite après ils ont tous
rouvert et ça a été une catastrophe
est ce que nous on prend pas un risque
de tout ouvrir on va en parler dans un
instant puisque on va parler des des
écoles dans le quart d'heure sans fil
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez au
hashtag avait hashtag démission blanc
caire est ce que nous on prend pas un
risque aussi de tourouvre ir comme ça
non mais ces situations qui est
complètement différente en fait c'était
la fausse idée qu'on pouvait éradiquer
le virus
vous pouvez sortir sans avoir vacciné la
totalité de sa population c'est cette
fameuse idée qu avec un zéro qu'ovide
globalement va se débarrasser du virus
mais pas du tout à ce que le virus
revienne et ça repart de plus belle de
temps qu'à aucune mesure de précaution
comme la france ne va pas complètement
tous relâchés d'un coup sans vaccination
ce quelqu un arbre il ya très peu de
gens pour l'instant qui sont vaccinés et
ben lancera pas dans la même situation
pour l'instant des plus proches des voix
que prennent israël le royaume est ce
que israël comment ça se passe et on
vacciner toute la population
est ce qu'aujourd'hui israël on peut
dire qu'ils ont vaincu le le coronavirus
ou pas du tout non pour l'instant ce
pour l'instant ils sont encore
relativement fermé en fait ils assurent
normalement ils ont rapaces sanitaires
ils peuvent pas aller dans un endroit
tel un restaurant sans avoir soit un
test négatif souhaitent vacciner soi
voire la sérologie qui montrent qu'ils
sont avérés ils sont dans la même
situation tous les autres pays qui
réouvre prudemment ce qui paye tout la
situation de l'inde s'est pas vaccinés
en plus une population il ya des
comorbidités beaucoup plus importants
tant ils sont beaucoup moins bien nutri
que nous donc forcément ça fait vraiment
un carnage et en plus ya eu ces fêtes
religieuses qui ont entraîné des
événements super contaminateur mais
peut-être
tout était réuni pour que ce soit
vraiment une situation catastrophique en
plus il y a eu cette espèce de fausse
idée on aime quand on avait acquis ce
qu'on appelle l'immunité qui donc tout
75 de la population avaient douché à peu
près et donc que ça y est c'est ça
c'était impossible parce qu'enfin il
faut que l'autre certain nombre de morts
pour avoir une immunité collective et
c'était pas du tout en lumière donc
c'était une idée qui était complètement
fausse l'effectif est ce que ça vous
fait flipper le vario indien delphine et
c'est pour ça en fait avec la naissance
de tous ces variants c'est pour ça que
faire comprendre aux jeunes qu'il faut
pas se rassembler il faut pas se réunir
et qu'il faut attendre pour faire les
fêtes
quand on voit ces images là qu'on voit à
quel point c'est vraiment très très très
très graves vers là lorsqu est très
important et je crois le dr bloch et
sera d'accord avec moi
les variants il y en aura encore
d'autres parce que c'est inhérent au
virus que dès qu'un virus il ya
plusieurs variants alors brésilien
maintenant ces indiens il y en aura
d'autres mais cela docteur à chaque fois
dans une vague épidémique invariante ici
invariants qui sort il y en aura
d'autres donc la seule solution c'est la
vaccination que ce soit avec les
attendait pour l'instant le vaccin et
marche surtout les variables dans les
conditions de la vie surtout les
variants effectivement dans le tube mais
semblait moins bien marché sur certains
accents donc le vaccin c'est quoi dans
le cul aujourd'hui les métiers comprend
du sérum de patients vaccinés et on met
le variant de d'accord là effectivement
les anticorps s'attache moi bien sûr les
variants mais quand vous l'essayez dans
la vraie vie il protège très bien les
gens qui sont vaccinées pour l'instant
on l'a fait sur le sud africain sur le
britannique on est en train de le faire
sur brésilien évidemment lundi on sait
pas et vient de sortir aux idées radine
moi je suis fille paix sur les aéroports
je trouve qu'on est nuls sur les
agresseurs agit de l'adie tout à l'heure
alors les gens qui viennent d'inde par
exemple il ya une quarantaine une
quarantaine de dix jours alors que dans
les autres pays c'est 14 jours et ils
peuvent sortir deux heures par jour
pardon mais pendant deux heures on peut
sortir on peut être super contaminants
mais je trouve qu'on devrait beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus ferme là dessus kelly
maladresse et ça que j'allais dire en
fait chaque gouvernement de chaque pays
n'apprend pas de ses erreurs parce qu'à
chaque fois on est choqué quand il ya un
nouveau variant qui arrivait par once de
mandat mais ce qui va arriver ou pas
mais en fait il fallait fermer les
frontières ou fallait être tout voler
les gens manière rigide avec les règles
plutôt que de les
agir là dessus si vous voulez fermer les
frontières il faut fermer les frontières
de la france à tous les pays du monde
marie sont indéterminées mais c'était
parce qu'en fait si vous aimez la photo
avec l'inde a du coup les gens font des
correspondances dans d'autres pays ainsi
qu'au contraire ça accélère
l'importation d'une variante de fermer
les lignes directes parce qu'en plus
vous contrôlez plus les flux mais
offrait trois questions les trois
questions parce que que se posent les
téléspectateurs le variant indien pour
vous il en france
quel bon c'est sûr très probablement en
france votre avis le vario anglais et il
faut encore que le variant indien c'est
ce qui est dit mais là je suis un degré
d'avoir dû prendre cette enseigne la et
sur le vaccin aussi on sait pas non plus
si on sait pas du tout mais probablement
qu'il garde une certaine efficacité on
sort à peu près quand vous pensez soit
relativement vite mais pas si rapidement
que ça très bien on va voir ce qu'on
pensait il vaut mieux qu'ils disent si
un mec rivière qui nous disent des
conneries on va s'en sortir oui à 69%
non à 31%